♪
AINSLEY: HEALTH OFFICIALS IN LAS
VEGAS NOW ADVISING TO MASK UP
INDOORS INCLUDING GROCERY
STORES, MALLS AND CASINOS, THIS
AS PEOPLE IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
MUST MASK UP INSIDE EVEN IF
THEY’RE FULLY VACCINATED, SO
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR
BUSINESSES TRYING TO GET BACK TO
NORMALCY?
OUR NEXT GUEST HAS HIS OWN
RESTAURANT OPENING UP IN VEGAS,
BAR RESCUE HOST JON TAFFER JOINS
US NOW.
HEY, JON.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
AINSLEY: THIS AFFECTS YOU AND SO
MANY OF YOUR FRIENDS.
>> FIRST OF ALL, I CAN’T BELIEVE
WE’RE STILL TALKING ABOUT THIS
NOW ALMOST A YEAR AND A HALF
LATER.
THERE’S A WHOLE DISTRESSING
ELEMENT TO IT.
THERE’S A FATIGUE, OBVIOUSLY,
UPON THE INDUSTRY THAT’S VERY
POWERFUL.
WHAT RUNS THE NATION IS NOT
FORCING RESTAURANTS TO DO IT,
BUT I WAS IN MOUNT RUSHMORE LAST
WEEK ON VACATION, AND, OF
COURSE, IT’S A NATIONAL
MONUMENT.
THERE ARE SIGNS WHEN YOU ENTER
THAT SAYS IF YOU’RE NOT
VACCINATED, MASK UP.
IF YOU ARE, YOU DON’T HAVE TO.
THERE WERE A COUPLE OF THOUSAND
PEOPLE THERE.
I DIDN’T SEE ONE PERSON WEARING
A MASK.
SO PEOPLE ARE NOT FOLLOWING
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS ANYMORE.
I THINK THEY’VE LEFT IT BEHIND.
BUT CLEARLY, STATISTICALLY THERE
WERE PEOPLE AT MOUNT RUSHMORE
WHO WEREN’T VACCINATED THAT,
OBVIOUSLY, WERE IGNORING THIS
RULE.
SO THE PROBLEM, I THINK, IS
GOING TO BE PUBLIC RESPONSE.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE OVER IT,
AINSLEY.
AND IS WE TALKED EVEN A YEAR AGO
THAT WE WERE CONCERNED IT WOULD
TAKE A LONG TIME FOR DEMAND TO
COME BACK.
WELL, LAS VEGAS IS PACKED.
THERE’S A HUGE PENT-UP DEMAND.
WE’RE SEEING IT ACROSS
RESTAURANTS ACROSS THE NATION.
WE’RE BUSY FROM A REVENUE
STANDPOINT.
I’M NOT SURE THE PUBLIC IS GOING
TO BUY INTO IT THIS TIME.
AINSLEY, IF I CANNED ADD ONE
MORE -- CAN ADD ONE MORE POINT.
BACK BEFORE THE ELECTION WHEN
THIS WAS THE, QUOTE, TRUMP
VACCINE, KAMALA HARRIS AND A
BUNCH OF DEMOCRATS PLAYED A VERY
ACTIVE ROLE IN DISCREDITING IT.
NOW THAT IT’S THE BIDEN VACCINE,
THEY’RE WEIGHING AND THEY’RE
ABSORBING THE RESULTS OF WHAT
THEY DID WHEN THEY DISCREDITED
IT EARLY ON.
MY POINT IS THIS: IF WE DIDN’T
DISCREDIT THIS PROCESS FROM THE
BEGINNING, THE PUBLIC WOULD
PROBABLY BE FAR MORE ACCEPTING
ABOUT IT.
WE’VE GOT A PROBLEM.
AMERICA’S NOT READY TO GET
VACCINATED, AND IT SHOULD, AND
AMERICANS AREN’T READY TO MASK
UP AGAIN, SO I’M NOT QUITE SURE
WHERE THIS LANDS, AINSLEY.
AINSLEY: YOU’RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
WE FEEL LIKE WE HAVE FREEDOM
AGAIN, WE CAN ACTUALLY SEE
PEOPLE’S MOUTHS WHEN THEY MOVE
AND THEY TALK, SO DO YOU THINK
THESE WORKERS -- A LOT OF THESE
WORKERS MIGHT HAVE HAD COVID,
AND THEY MIGHT HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED.
DO YOU THINK THEY’RE GOING TO GO
ALONG WITH THIS, AND WILL IT
HURT THE BOTTOM LINE?
ARE SOME PEOPLE GOING TO SAY IS,
LOOK, I’M NOT GOING TO GO TO THE
CASINOS IF THEY’RE GOING TO MAKE
ME WEAR A MASK?
I’M JUST NOT GOING TO SPEND MY
MONEY IN THESE RESTAURANTS.
>> I THINK THAT’S A REAL
REALITY.
WE LOOK AT GAMING, FOR EXAMPLE,
WHICH DRIVES LAS VEGAS, THE
LONGER YOU SIT, THE MORE YOU
PLAY, THE MORE MONEY WE MAKE.
YOU’RE NOT GOING TO SIT AS LONG
WHEN YOU’RE UNCOMFORTABLE
WEARING A MASK.
SO IT HAS A PROFOUND IMPACT ON
GAMING, IT HAS A PROFOUND IMPACT
ON BARS WHEN PEOPLE STAY FOR
LONGER PERIODS OF TIME.
AND I AGREE WITH YOU COMPLETELY,
I THINK THE PUBLIC IS OVER THIS,
AND THEY’RE HAVING A HARD TIME
LOOKING BACK AT THIS POINT.
AINSLEY: I KNOW.
NO ONE’S THROWING AWAY THEIR
MASKS.
MINE ARE CLEAN AND IN A CABINET
IN MY KITCHEN, BECAUSE I’M JUST
WORRIED WE’RE GOING TO HAVE TO
PULL THEM BACK OUT AGAIN.
WHAT’S THE NAME OF YOUR NEW